this uh this is this is crazy to say
but courts around the country court
houses
are bracing for violence
as a result of donald trump now being
under three criminal investigations it
almost sounds surreal what
it's
courts are bracing for violence because
trump is being how could how would that
be well yes
it is 2022 and that's the reality that
we live in um i have an article from a
business insider trump is facing
criminal investigations into his conduct
courts are bracing for violence and
chaos
um donald trump encouraged supporters to
protest where he and his company are
under investigation fulton county
district attorney fanny willis and other
officials aren't taking his comments
lightly officials in new york atlanta
and washington d.c are investigating
whether trump broke the law
um
the uh these cities are taking uh trump
at his word and preparing for the worst
in atlanta
uh fannie willis requested that the fbi
assess the security of fulton county
courthouse and other government
buildings i'm asking that you
immediately conduct a risk assessment
and you provide protective resources
one big reason for concern around trump
is simply his presence in a courthouse a
case or cases of this magnitude would
likely draw big crowds this would mean
more work for law enforcement and secret
service
um
we have uh the video of course of trump
at his recent rally actually saying we
there should be major protests depending
on what happens with these
investigations
if these radical vicious racist
prosecutors do anything wrong or illegal
i hope we are going to have in this
country the biggest protest we have ever
had in washington dc in new york in
atlanta and elsewhere because our
country and our elections are corrupt
now understand that the code of what
he's saying when he says if they do
anything illegal and corrupt to me in
those places but what he's really saying
is
if they do anything
i will tell you that it is illegal and
corrupt
if there are any charges
brought forward out of new york
out of atlanta out of washington dc at
the federal level what he's going to say
that it is corruption and that it is
illegal and he is already ginning up
exactly the type of violence that we saw
on january 6th though on the one hand
when we say courts bracing for violence
what courts brace yeah it makes perfect
sense
of someone facing criminal charges and
the court system has to physically brace
for violence well yeah look at what
happened on january 6. in fact we almost
need to fortify the court buildings
because we can't
count
on
it all being dealt with appropriately
outside those buildings because of what
we saw on january 6th i mean hopefully
it would be different hopefully in in
atlanta or in new york it would be
handled differently and knowing what
happened on january 6th they would be
prepared but it's a real and crazy thing
that this is being discussed
the far right is sort of being
worked up into a lather
of seething anger
at someone for all of the things and
injustices that they perceive to have
been carried out against them
and
there are certainly injustices that have
been carried out against the average
person when we talk about the two
justice systems we have when we talk
about our economic system allowing and
even causing such inequality and
disenfranchisement of course but
their ire is being pointed at the wrong
place
at election systems that are supposedly
fraudulent at investigative systems that
are supposedly targeting trump with the
so-called witch hunts they are being
told something's going to have to be
done
but it always ends up being
a cynical use of these people by trump
either for their money or as we saw on
january 6th
for their it's almost like for their
freedom they traded their freedom for
trump when he said let's go to the
capitol and more than 700 of them now
facing uh criminal charges so this is a
keg
that could very well explode now i think
it's important to mention one additional
thing
i
fear
a rise in violence
regardless of what happens to trump and
what i mean by that is trump in and of
himself is not the root cause
of
the weaponized xenophobia and
disinformation and authoritarian leaning
he identified it as a good way to wrap
up this electorate that was to some
degree made up of people that were not
really even following politics up until
trump swooped in and said hey here's how
you can get involved and help me rise to
power
i worry that those people
are uh
likely
plausibly going to become violent over
the next couple of years even without it
being trump directing them to go to
courthouses and cities where he is
potentially facing charges which again i
still don't think is the most likely
outcome i think that there's a
propensity here for violence regardless
and that's a really scary thing if you
disagree with me
let me know you can find me on twitter
at deepakman
one of our sponsors is cometier coffee
cometier coffee is delicious i can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their brewing process captures
over 2 000 flavor compounds then the
coffee is flash frozen locking in the
flavor it arrives at your home frozen in
a fully recyclable capsule all you have
to do is melt it by adding hot water or
cold water for iced coffee it takes
seconds it's the most convenient way
that i have ever made coffee i've been
impressed with how the process protects
the flavor i really enjoy cometier they
have a variety of flavor options light
medium and dark single origin and
blended coffee roasts from the best
specialty roasters you'll get twenty
dollars off when you go to cometeer.com
pacman the link is underneath this video